drôle d'ambiance depuis saint paul cette
petite voiture électrique entre dans la
montagne
et
mais de 9 km de lignes droites sur des
dalles et en dessous l'eau du
basculement au marchand actuellement sur
des grands réservoirs des grands bassins
qui sont en longueur et nous allons
déplacer
aller jusqu'à
crise qui s'apparente à un mini barrages
petit barrage dans le lit de la rivière
des galets
cet ouvrage départemental de captation
appartient aux périmètres hydro
agricoles de l'irrigation du littoral
ouest sous la gestion de la six
c'est la première prise de ma femme la
plus grosse dans le lit de la rivière
des galets donc ça représente ici on
peut capter jusqu'à 1300 l'ict seconde à
limone la côte ouest la possession
jusqu'à à piton saint leu
le but de ce ouvrage c'est de capter une
partie de l'eau de la rivière des galets
d'assurer une continuité hydraulique
derrière moi vous avez une passe à
poissons cas sur le passage des poissons
même quand on capte parce que là bas
nous avons de grandes marches et donc
cet ouvrage n'est pas le seul nous avons
un ouvrage de captage également dans le
bras de sainte-suzanne toujours nos
cirques de mafate et deux ouvrages de
captage au niveau de la rivière du mât
et la rigueur fleurs jaunes non le
simple de salaire une installation dont
le bassin versant de mafate qui fait
partie d'un grand ensemble département a
vraiment cette volonté de d'apporter
l'eau sur de grands territoires donc nos
réseaux se comporte un petit peu comme
des autoroutes de l'eau et ce qui nous
permet de
de répondre à un phénomène de sécheresse
aux fortes pluies qui forcent à akoupé
tel ou tel stockage et aujourd'hui tout
l'enjeu et qui a été mis en avant ces
derniers temps par les différentes
difficultés qu'on a eu tout l'enjeu de
notre travail est d'arriver à
interconnecter les réseaux arriver à
trouver des solutions pour diversifier
la ressource globale raisonnée c'est
l'un des objectifs du basculement de
l'aude est en ouest
un chantier pluriannuel l'occasion de
faire un point sur l'avancement du
projet naviguez 60% des terres à eric et
donc on a déjà rempli 60% des objectifs
d'irrigation les 48% était conditionnée
par la mobilisation de la ressource de
salazie donc la possibilité de ramener
l'eau de salazie jusqu'à mon repos
la solution a été trouvée puisque nous
avons finalisé la galerie salazienne et
du coup nous allons pouvoir avancer dans
notre programme et irriguer le reste on
compte aboutir
pour la plupart des poux secteur irrigué
pour 2016
les portes se ferment sur cette
installation titanesque sens qui
aujourd'hui il serait bien difficile de
fonctionner